PLEASURE TO TALK TO YOU.
THANK YOU.
>> MY PLEASURE.
TRULY.
>> TAKE CARE.
BE CAREFUL.
SOME OF THE ELECTION DENIALISM
DRIVING THE SUSPICION ABOUT
EARLY VOTING COMING FOR KARI
LAKE.
THERE IS SOMETHING ELSE IN
ADDITION TO THAT.
IT COULD BE, BY THE CANDIDATE'S
OWN ADMISSION, WHICH YOU WILL
HEAR, PUT ARIZONA ON A COLLISION
COURSE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
>> YOU GUYS TURNED OUT TODAY.
>> IN THE RACE FOR ARIZONA
GOVERNOR, YOU HEAR THIS FROM
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE KARI LAKE ON
HER PLAN FOR BORDER SECURITY.
>> IT'S CALLED OUR ARTICLE 1,
SECTION 10, RIGHTS UNDER THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION.
>> ARTICLE 1, SECTION 10, UNITED
STATES SCHOOL SHOOTINGS.
WE ARE GOING TO INVOKE ARTICLE
1, SECTION 10, BASICALLY,
AUTHORITY TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
BORDER.
>> Reporter: THAT BORDER IS AN
INTERNATIONAL BORDER.
SO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CONTROLS IT.
BUT SHE INTERPRETS THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION TO MEAN SHE COULD
DO THIS.
>> AS GOVERNOR I WILL ISSUE A
DECLARATION OF INVASION, FINISH
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S WALL, BLOW UP
THE CARTEL'S DRUG TUNNELS AND
SURVEILLANCE DRONES AND DEPLOY
THE ARIZONA NATIONAL GUARD TO
STOP ILLEGALS FROM ENTERING.
>> Reporter: THOSE EX EMPLOYINGS
AND DRONES ARE COMPUTER
GENERATED FWRACHKS TO ILLUSTRATE
HER POINT.
SOMETHING ECHOED BY FELLOW
ARIZONA REPUBLICAN AND U.S.
SENATE NOMINEE BLAKE MASTERS,
ALSO USING COMPUTER GRAPHICS IN
HIS AD.
>> THIS IS AN INVASION.
WE KNOW WHAT TO DO.
WE NEED TO FINISH TRUMP'S WALL.
>> Reporter: ARIZONA STATE
UNIVERSITY LAW PROFESSOR ANGELA
BANKS SAYS THE REASON THE
NOMINEES USE THE WORD INVASION
--
>> BY DECLARING THERE HAS BEEN
AN INVASION THEY BELIEVE THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO EXERCISE THE
FEDERAL POWERS THAT ARE
ARTICULATED IN ARTICLE 1,
SECTION 10.
HOWEVER, THE ONLY SPECIFIC POWER
RELEVANT FOR STATES TO ENGAGE IN
WOULD BE THE POWER TO ENGAGE IN
WAR.
>> Reporter: A MINOR DETAIL THAT
KARI LAKE SKIPS ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL.
>> IF YOU HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING
ME
FOR ONE SECOND, I AM GOING TO
DECLARE AN INVASION ON DAY ONE,
HOUR ONE.
I DON'T CARE IF WE HAVE TO FIGHT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE
FAKE NEWS EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
>> Reporter: THAT HARD-LINE
STANCE IS POPULAR AMONG THE
REPUBLICAN BASE IN ARIZONA, A
BORDER STATE THAT HAS SEEN THE
INFLUX OF MIGRANTS AND DRUGS.
OUTGOING REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR
DUCEY DEUCE MOVED MORE THAN 100
SHIPPING CONTAINERS TO TRY TO
PLUG HOLES IN THE BORDER OVER
THE SUMMER.
A MOVE THAT HAS LANDED HIS
ACTION IN COURT.
AND THAT'S WHERE LAKE'S
CONSTITUTIONAL PLAN WOULD LIKELY
END UP.
>> IS THIS MORE POLITICAL
RHETORIC OR DOES THIS LEGALLY
SEEM FEASIBLE TO YOU?
>> SO I THINK THIS IS A LOT OF
POLITICAL RHETORIC AND SO I
THINK WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS AN
EFFORT TO TURN THAT RHETORIC
THAT HAS BEEN USED IN THE PUBLIC
DISCOURSE INTO SOMETHING LEGALLY
MEANINGFUL AND I THINK THAT IS
WHERE THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
QUESTIONS AS TO WHETHER THAT
WILL BE SUCCESSFUL.
>> Reporter: WELL, LAWYERS SAY
NEVER SAY NEVER.
LEGAL EXPERTS HAVE BEEN
SURPRISED AT THE SHIFT IN THE
WAY COURTS HAVE LOOKED AT
IMMIGRATION.
NOW, IF A GOVERNOR, KARI LAKE,
IS SKETCH ON THIS, NOT JUST IN
POLICY BUT IN THE COURTS, IT
WOULD CHANGE THE WAY COURTS VIEW
IMMIGRATION AND ALSO, ANDERSON,
TH